♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
- J'ai eu envie de dessiner
comment je me sentais.
- La fausse couche
est une réalité méconnue,
même taboue, bien qu'elle touche
en moyenne 1 grossesse sur 5.
CAROLYNE LEBLANC, chanteuse
et musicienne, groupe Raffy
- J'ai décidé d'écrire comment
je l'ai vécu, que j'ai partagé,
puis je me serais jamais
attendue à cette réaction-là.
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
- Musicienne et chanteuse
du groupe Raffy, Carolyne
filait le parfait bonheur avec
son amoureux depuis 13 ans.
- Ça allait super bien, là!
Le film de Disney par
excellence : on se marie,
on s'achète une maison, il y a
un petit bébé qui s'en vient.
- Enceinte de trois mois,
leur projet de fonder
une famille s'effondre.
- Puis un soir, sur scène,
je suis en train de chanter puis
je commence à avoir vraiment
des grosses douleurs au ventre.
Et le lendemain, je m'en vais
chez le médecin, il tente
d'écouter le coeur du bébé,
il l'entend pas...
- On va aller porter le biberon.
- On a fait un petit mausolée
pour le bébé.
- Véronique a fait sa fausse
couche il y a quelques semaines
à peine. Son conjoint et elle
ont vécu cette épreuve entourés
de leurs deux garçons.
VÉRONIQUE RIOPEL
- C'est un moment marquant dans
sa vie. On pense jamais que
ça peut nous arriver.
- Après la tristesse
et l'incompréhension, le silence
et la culpabilité s'installent.
- C'est un peu aussi pour ça
que c'est tabou, t'sais,
les gens, ils n'en parlent pas
parce que ça peut être gênant.
- Tu te sens vraiment vide,
tu te sens honteuse aussi, c'est
plate, je sais qu'il n'y avait
pas de honte à ressentir, mais
tu la ressens, cette honte-là,
un gros sentiment d'échec.
- C'est pas après quelques jours
qu'on se remet de la perte
d'un enfant.
- Julie Charbonneau anime des
cafés causeries à l'organisme
Parents Orphelins.
La femme, qui a perdu quatre
bébés durant ses grossesses,
est très bien placée pour
accompagner les familles
qui vivent un deuil.
JULIE CHARBONNEAU, membre C. A.
Association Parents Orphelins
- C'est un processus,
c'est un cheminement,
c'est une réadaptation en soi,
le deuil périnatal.
♪ Someday I'll wish
upon a star ♪
- Une démarche dans laquelle
Carolyne et son conjoint
se sont sentis bien seuls.
- J'ai trouvé qu'il y a eu
vraiment un gros manque, c'est
qu'on m'a envoyée chez moi
sans me dire c'était quoi
la suite. Donc moi : "Ton bébé
est mort, tu fais une fausse
couche, bonne chance."
- Il y a beaucoup de monde qui
n'est pas au courant qu'il y a
ces ressources-là.
- Camille Maheu accompagne
des couples dans l'aventure
de la parentalité; lorsqu'une
fausse couche survient,
elle oriente les parents
vers le soutien approprié.
CAMILLE MAHEU, v.-p. Asso Qc
accompagnantes à la naissance
- C'est épuisant au départ quand
on le sait qu'on va se buter
à un manque de ressources.
- CLSC, maisons de la famille,
des lieux où les couples
endeuillés peuvent trouver
de l'écoute et du réconfort.
- Il faut comme tomber sur
la bonne infirmière qui va être
capable de donner comme la liste
de toutes les ressources.
- Ça demeure malgré tout
banalisé par les professionnels
de la santé, par les gens
souvent de l'entourage et par
les employeurs, malheureusement.
- Lundi, je suis rentrée au
travail comme si rien n'était.
- La routine et les obligations
du quotidien ont rapidement
rattrapé Véronique.
- Même si tu vis une fausse
couche avant 20 semaines,
s'il peut y avoir un programme
au niveau de l'aide
psychologique.  Sinon, au niveau
professionnel, c'est d'avoir
plus de mesures de conciliation
famille-travail.
- Idéalement, on vivrait
dans une société où dès qu'on a
un résultat positif, on peut se
permettre la joie de le partager
avec les gens autour de nous,
puis si quelques semaines après,
malheureusement, on perd notre
bébé, qu'on puisse en parler
aussi puis que ce soit accueilli
de la bonne façon, que
notre employeur nous permette de
prendre deux semaines de congé.
- Depuis que je l'ai vécu,
j'ai appris tellement
d'histoires de gens autour
de moi de gens que
j'aurais jamais pensé.
- Pour briser le tabou, Carolyne
pense que le risque de fausse
couche devrait être abordé
dès le premier suivi médical.
- Dès que quelqu'un pense avoir
un enfant, en parler, expliquer
que c'est une possibilité
malheureusement, mais au moins
la personne, elle peut
se préparer à ça, puis elle peut
se faire moins d'attentes.
- Et plus que tout,
elle aimerait qu'on cesse
de mettre de la pression
sur les couples.
- Demander à un couple : "Hé!
Ça fait longtemps que vous êtes
ensemble. À quand les enfants?"
Peut-être qu'ils n'en veulent
pas, peut-être qu'ils ont essayé
puis que ça marche pas, peut-
être qu'ils viennent d'en perdre
un... Parce que c'est vraiment
une question qui fait mal.
- Donc aujourd'hui, on boucle
un peu la boucle, c'est-à-dire
que je vais à la clinique pour
vérifier si tout est beau.
- Véronique souhaite que
son histoire inspire plusieurs
femmes à briser le silence
entourant la fausse couche.
- Pour pouvoir tourner la page,
puis peut-être s'essayer
à nouveau.
- Quant à Carolyne, son conjoint
et elle ont toujours le souhait
de fonder une famille.
♪ Dreams that you dream
of dream ♪
- C'est sûr qu'on en a beaucoup
reparlé, je pense qu'on le
regretterait, on le regretterait
de pas avoir d'enfants.
♪ ♪ ♪